my next question is about the Holy
Spirit okay what about um so coming from
a charismatic background right
um they Define the holy spirit in sort
of
a in a different way because
um um they they sort of view the upper
room event to be a significant event
that could be something that um that
tells you that you have the Holy Spirit
yeah they believe of the Holy Spirit
where you speak in tongues and that's
not in the in the book of
Acts okay yeah you're going to
charismatic church that says you need to
be speaking in tongues as sign you've
been baptized in the Holy Spirit the
baptism Holy Spirit which is evidenced
by speaking in tongues which is an
additional gift and power you receive
after your salvation that's a unique
teaching to the charismatics is not
biblical because in the book of Acts not
everyone who received the Holy Spirit
spoke in tongues in Acts 9 when Paul in
Acts 22 and acts 9 when Paul was
baptized he didn't speak in
Tong and acts 8:26 to39 when the
Ethiopian unic was baptized he didn't
speak in
tongues in Acts 16 30-34 when the Jailer
was baptized he didn't speak in
tongues so they will show you the
examples where people spoke in tongues
or languages but ignore those examples
where people didn't
right right so no
that's right so so so what is what are
the essential elements that one needs
to um become baptized in the Holy Spirit
what the moment you confess turn to
Christ and are baptized in water you
have received the Holy
Spirit that's it well I mean I kind of
did that back in my you kind of did it
did you get baptized I yeah I mean they
believe in most baptized as an infant uh
not as an infant no okay what church did
you get baptized in um The Universal
Church of the kingdom of God it's it's a
global church it's called The U ucg what
do they believe they what the
ucg okay but what do they
believe um wow so I'm not very good with
about the Trinity what do they believe
about the trinity oh yeah they
definitely and what name did they
baptize you in the father son and H Holy
Spirit they trinitarian well that
according to scripture when you
confess repent and are baptized in water
you're given the Holy Spirit that's it
then they're teaching you yeah but
you're not baptized in the Holy Spirit
they're wrong they're wrong they don't
know that's their one of their unique
Traditions that's not biblical but
coming back to the
point well anyway so are you still in
that church or you leaving to be you're
looking to leave the church and go to
the Orthodox Church yeah I'm I'm looking
at Orthodoxy I just need to sort of get
my head why do you why do you care what
the charismatic church is telling you uh
I mean I guess that's that was my roots
isn't it um but you're leaving so either
you stay there and agree to what they're
telling you which you don't agree
because you're questioning or who cares
what they think CU you're not in line
with them because if you're staying
there then they're telling you how to
speak in tongues well you can't faking
and force yourself to speak in tongues
and as long as you don't speak in
tongues they're going to consider you're
not baptized in the Holy Spirit and
they're wrong so do you care what they
think or are you leaving
it well I guess I guess I've got to
leave man um yeah leave I would tell you
leave go to the Orthodox Church what are
you waitting and then when you go to the
Orthodox Church then that priest or
Bishop will tell you whether they
recognize your baptism and I don't think
they will they're going to tell you you
got to get baptized I don't think
they'll accept now not don't quote me on
this I can be mistaken some Orthodox
priests have been told like in one case
there was a sister was a Muslim she got
baptized in Protestant church one
Orthodox priest says you only need to be
chrismated someone El said no no no
she's got to get baptized again I would
be surprised if they told you that you
got to get if they didn't tell you you
got to get baptized again because they
don't I would I'd be shocked if they
accepted the baptism of this
church wow that is
yeah that's tough to him man that's
tough to him well it's because sadly
right now in the current state of
Christianity we have over 40,000
different groups professing to be
Christian and so it's chaos and
confusion the Orthodox Church is very
strict on what baptism they will
recognize because they don't believe
every baptism is valid and pleasing to
God so since you're looking into the
Orthodox Church like I said I'll be
if they say your baptism is
valid but again I may be wrong because
even Hank hgraph Hank henra was this
very famous figure known as the Bible
answer man who used to do a Daily Show
answering Bible questions and
interviewing Scholars and apologists who
was a Protestant several years ago he
got chrismated in the Greek Orthodox
Church chrismated means that they
accepted his baptism so all he had to do
was get chrismated
what is crism sorry that is a process in
which you are brought into communion
with the Orthodox church it's called
crism now
chrismation basically anointing right
like kristos comes from the anointed one
because you're anointed and that's
symbolic of being anointed by the Holy
Spirit right I see yeah so who cares
what the charismatics say go to the
Orthodox church and take it from
there so don't worry about go to the
orthodo ask question say okay look this
is my background I'm interested I want
to learn and if I embrace it once I get
baptized again go ask
them right right yeah any other
questions though I mean related
to because that's you've already s you
already settled that issue what do I
mean you've already now determined I
want to head towards the Orthodox church
so who cares what they say man
yeah I guess I guess you're right yeah
definitely but if you care then you're
going to have to accept what they teach
and they're saying you got to speak in
tongues to show you're baptized the Holy
Spirit and that's not true not everyone
speaks in tongues they are
misinterpreting the book of Acts and
when it talks about gifts even in 1
Corinthians 12 when it lists the gifts
if you read it and you read 1
Corinthians 12
28-31 specifically 3031 Paul himself
says not everyone speaks in tongues he
says it not everyone ah okay it's in for
let me show
1 Corinthians 12 all the gifts are
mentioned but at the end of it which is
the most important aspect at the end of
it he will tell you clearly not everyone
speaks in tongues here it is at the end
right here
boing it's not me it's Paul so this
insistent on speaking tongues that's
because they're butchering the book of
Acts and don't understand
it and God has appointed the church
first
apostles highest ranking King in the
church at the time was Apostles second
prophets third teachers then Miracles
then those who do Miracles then Gifts of
healings and helps some are gifted help
people administrations because you also
have to know Administration how to run
the Church of God various kinds of
tongues are all Apostles what's the
answer were they all
Apostles um yeah well no sorry no you're
about to come me are all
prophets I guess not no are all
teachers no are all workers of Miracles
nope do all have gifts of
healings certainly not do all speak with
tongues uh I guess not then do all
translate nope thank you so why don't
they tell you this 1 Corinthians 1228 to
wow wow boy I have a lot to learn man
yeah that's why you need to leave and go
to the Orthodox Church because number
one the Orthodox church has been there
from the start this is a fact
historically Protestants will tell you
before the Reformation you had the
Catholic Orthodox that's number one so
number two in Protestant land you're
going to be confused you're going to a
charismatic church that says You must be
baptized Holy Spirit and the evidence of
as you speak in tongues but then you go
to another Protestant Church says no
those gifts were signs sign gifts given
to prove that the church is from God
once the church is established you don't
need those gifts anymore and they're
called
secessionists
okay you understand so in protestantism
you're going to have someone telling you
no those gifts have seized they're not
for the church today they're called
secessionists others say no they
continue and even those who believe they
continue not all of them say You must
speak in tongues and yet others do you
see so you're going to be in
confusion yeah yeah yeah there there is
a lot to learn clearly told by Paul not
everyone will speak in tongues not
everyone will interpret just like not
everyone has the power to heal and now
everyone's Apostle and then he says seek
the greater gifts you know what the
greater gifts is he tells you in the
next chapter faith hope and love and
love being the greatest of all pursue
those gifts he says in the next chapter
man he goes seek to have love because
God wants everyone to have love and
Faith and Hope
here if I speak with tongues of men and
angels but do not have love I become a
noising gong or a clanging symbol if I
have the gift of Prophecy and know all
Mysteries and all knowledge if I have
all Faith so as to remove mountains but
do not have love I am nothing and if I
give all my possessions to feed the poor
and if I Surrender my body to be burnt
but do not have love it profits mean
nothing this is greater than tongues
greater than healing love that's what he
said love is patient love is kind it's
not jealous does not brag it's not
puffed up does not act unbecomingly does
not seek its own is not provoked does
not take into account a wrongs suffered
it does not rejoice in unrighteousness
but rejoices with the truth it Bears all
things believes all things hope all
things endures all things Love Never
Fails but if there are Gifts of Prophecy
they'll be done away with you won't need
to prophesy when Jesus comes it's done
if there are tongues they will seize if
there's knowledge you'll be done away
with you don't need to be given
knowledge anymore cuz Christ Has Come
For we know in part and we prophesy in
part but when the perfect comes when
Christ comes to perfect us and completes
us the partial will be done away with
when I was a child I used to speak like
a child think like a child reason like a
child when I became a man I did away
with child those things for now we see
in a mirror dimly we only see partially
not completely but then face to face I
will be face to face with Jesus he will
then Transform Me
and my
imperfection will turn into Perfection
now I know in part but then I will know
fully just as I also have been fully
known so what are the greatest gifts but
now abide faith hope and love these
three seek for these three because God
wants everyone to have these gifts but
the greatest of these is love when's the
last time you heard them tell you
this they do talk about it a little bit
but they like to talk about the gifts as
well but did all focus on tongues or do
he focus on love Faith and Hope love on
love definitely and did he say everyone
speaks in tongues no so these are the
parts of the Bible they conveniently
overlook